let's say you uh share a house with uh
three of the roommates and each have a
bedroom
and uh one of your roommates opens his
window and starts letting strangers come
into the house they go in the kitchen
start eating your food they're in their
living room watching TV and you're like
who are you people how did you get in
here and they're like we live here now
and then you're like yeah no no no no
you're not allowed to come in here oh no
he let us in that's what California is
doing California quite literally is a
sanctuary State and they're allowing
people to illegally enter to a certain
degree offering them resources and then
these people use California as their
entry point and then go through other
words don't get me wrong they're still
illegally crossing in Arizona and Texas
and the federal government's doing
nothing about it but California is
abusing this these ideas they're using
it to fluff their their population
numbers their their their census numbers
so they actually had I think in the
previous in the 2010s they had an extra
congressional seat and an extra
Electoral College vote because they
allowed non-citizens into the country